hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and once again I'm joined by Aaron of
the game grumps and or Eagle Raptor
Brian and
problems and we're gonna play a game
that everyone doesn't seem to want to
play except for me that's the electro
shot game that everyone knows about
right it's gonna be so fun yeah I'm
ready I don't like it it's it's
randomized how long it is the first one
to press it does not get shocked
everyone else does get shot let's get
ready that's not how it is you say
that's the normal one only one person
gets shot no no no no no the only
adopted one oh oh geez I've gotta I'm
not gonna lie it's actually more intense
than you think it is oh no there you go
okay
Jesus
no come on man oh I hate this
yeah
okay my heart was just racing like I was
like my vision was going blurry I was
thinking about it was it's a little
worse than I thought it was yeah okay
but no no it's fine let's do it again
we're all friends
this is things that friends do no I'm
feeling I'm gonna fail every time I just
have the slowest reflexes you're like a
gamer are you gonna do this I like it we
should do it online
it's all alive
okay not yet
my hands are so sweaty right now I hate
shot that only gets one of us yeah oh
damn it I like that though oh that's I
thought I wanted never mind all right
well so now it's
one shot for me and Aaron put it up on
the scoreboard one shot for me and Mark
yay
I actually have played this game before
Oh man oh man God damn it [__] this [__]
oh my God damn
I'm so in the zone
wait don't press it early yes
okay Mark
we'll fix that
this is bull this is oh this video is
supposed to be me laughing at you guys
that's three times three times oh man I
am like that's the only one who's gone
dude if you put it together it's like
the old PS3 controller remember that
[__] oh yeah
look at that nice that's nice I don't
know I didn't go with that
I'm not gonna lose
I guess I accidentally pressed it I'm
like I'm dizzy right now you haven't
done anything I know but I'm just like
you're gonna have a heart attack before
you even get shot you're [__] [__]
I don't like this
yes
you guys want to do it eyes closed yeah
no cheating no cheese no bumps on the
button wait no thumbs on the button now
God damn it it was me
I'm always even like oh God damn it oh
damn
I just want to hear it just one person
reaction just [__]
this for all teams
oh wait eyes closed
stop
did you do this
we should do this one toaster in a
bathtub awesome all right close your
eyes guys okay closing eyes
it never does it fast does it sometimes
God damn it
damn it
oh [__] [__]
no anyway
yeah we do this guy you guys did it good
job yeah
foreign
so that's the end of the electro shock
challenge thanks to all my guests for
joining me Ryan Matt and Aaron
thank you oh dude my pleasure check the
links in the description to their stuff
and thanks again for watching it was
nothing but a joy let us know what other
cool games you want us to play in the
future thanks again and as always we'll
see you
bye see you advice